PROFESSOR: Well, yesterday we
learned a bit about symbolic
manipulation, and we wrote a
rather stylized program to
implement a pile of calculus
rule from the calculus book.
Here on the transparencies, we
see a bunch of calculus rules
from such a book.
And, of course, what we did is
sort of translate these rules
into the language
of the computer.
But, of course, that's a
sort of funny strategy.
Why should we have to translate
these rules into the
language of the computer?
And what do I really
mean by that?
These are--the program we wrote
yesterday was very stylized.
It was a conditional, a dispatch
on the type of the
expression as observed
by the rules.
What we see here are rules that
say if the object being
the derivative is being taken
of, if that expression is a
constant, then do one thing.
If it's a variable,
do another thing.
If it's a product of a constant
times a variable, do
something and so on.
There's sort of a dispatch
there on a type.
Well, since it has such a
stylized behavior and
structure, is there some other
way of writing this program
that's more clear?
Well, what's a rule,
first of all?
What are these rules?
Let's think about that.
Rules have parts.
If you look at these rules in
detail, what you see, for
example, is the rule has
a left-hand side and a
right-hand side.
Each of these rules has a
left-hand side and the
right-hand side.
The left-hand side is somehow
compared with the expression
you're trying to take
the derivative of.
The right-hand side is the
replacement for that
expression.
So all rules on this page
are something like this.
I have patterns, and somehow,
I have to produce, given a
pattern, a skeleton.
This is a rule.
A pattern is something that
matches, and a skeleton is
something you substitute into
in order to get a new
expression.
So what that means is that the
pattern is matched against the
expression, which is the
source expression.
And the result of the
application of the rule is to
produce a new expression, which
I'll call a target, by
instantiation of a skeleton.
That's called instantiation.
So that is the process by which
these rules are described.
What I'd like to do today is
build a language and a means
of interpreting that language,
a means of executing that
language, where that language
allows us to directly express
these rules.
And what we're going to do is
instead of bringing the rules
to the level of the computer by
writing a program that is
those rules in the computer's
language--
at the moment, in a Lisp--
we're going to bring the
computer to the level of us by
writing a way by which the
computer can understand rules
of this sort.
This is slightly emphasizing the
idea that we had last time
that we're trying to make
a solution to a class of
problems rather than
a particular one.
The problem is if I want to
write rules for a different
piece of mathematics, say,
to simple algebraic
simplification or something like
that, or manipulation of
trigonometric functions,
I would have to write a
different program in using
yesterday's method.
Whereas I would like to
encapsulate all of the things
that are common to both of those
programs, meaning the
idea of matching, instantiation,
the control
structure, which turns out to be
very complicated for such a
thing, I'd like to encapsulate
that separately from the rules
themselves.
So let's look at, first of
all, a representation.
I'd like to use the
overhead here.
I'd like-- there it is.
I'd like to look at a
representation of the rules of
calculus for derivatives in a
sort of simple language that
I'm writing right here.
Now, I'm going to avoid--I'm
going to avoid
worrying about syntax.
We can easily pretty this, and
I'm not interested in making--
this is indeed ugly.
This doesn't look like the
beautiful text set dx by dt or
something that I'd
like to write,
but that's not essential.
That's sort of an accidental
phenomenon.
Here, we're just worrying
about the fact that the
structure of the rules is that
there is a left-hand side
here, represents the thing I
want to match against the
derivative expression.
This is the representation
I'm going to say for the
derivative of a constant, which
we will call c with
respect to the variable we will
call v. And what we will
get on the right-hand
side is 0.
So this represents a rule.
The next rule will be the
derivative of a variable,
which we will call v with
respect to the same variable
v, and we get a 1.
However, if we have the
derivative of a variable
called u with respect to
a different variables
v, we will get 0.
I just want you look at these
rules a little bit and see how
they fit together.
For example, over here, we're
going to have the derivative
of the sum of an expression
called x1 and an
expression called x2.
These things that begin with
question marks are called
pattern variables in the
language that we're inventing,
and you see we're just making
it up, so pattern variables
for matching.
And so in this--
here we have the derivative of
the sum of the expression
which we will call x1.
And the expression we will call
x2 with respect to the
variable we call v will be--
here is the right-hand side:
the sum of the derivative of
that expression x1 with
respect to v-- the right-hand
side is the skeleton--
and the derivative of x2 with
respect to v. Colons here will
stand for substitution
objects.
They're--we'll call them
skeleton evaluations.
So let me put up here on the
blackboard for a second some
syntax so we'll know
what's going on
for this rule language.
First of all, we're going to
have to worry about the
pattern matching.
We're going to have things like
a symbol like foo matches
exactly itself.
The expression f of a and b will
be used to match any list
whose first element is f, whose
second element is a, and
whose third element is b.
Also, another thing we might
have in a pattern is that--
a question mark with some
variable like x.
And what that means, it says
matches anything, which we
will call x.
Question mark c x will
match only constants.
So this is something which
matches a constant colon x.
And question mark v x will
match a variable,
which we call x.
This is sort of the language
we're making up now.
If I match two things against
each other, then they are
compared element by element.
But elements in the pattern may
contain these syntactic
variables, pattern variables,
which will be used to match
arbitrary objects.
And we'll get that object as the
value in the name x here,
for example.
Now, when we make skeletons
for instantiation.
Well, then we have
things like this.
foo, a symbol, instantiates
to itself.
Something which is a list
like f of a and b,
instantiates to--
well, f instantiates to a
3-list, a list of three
elements, okay, which are the
results of instantiating each
of f, a, and b.
And x well--we instantiate to
the value of x as in the
matched pattern.
So going back to the overhead
here, we see--we see that all
of those kinds of objects, we
see here a pattern variable
which matches a constant, a
pattern variable which matches
a variable, a pattern variable
which will match anything.
And if we have two instances of
the same name, like this is
the derivative of the expression
which is a variable
only whose name will be v with
respect to some arbitrary
expression which we will call v,
since this v appears twice,
we're going to want that to mean
they have to be the same.
The only consistent match is
that those are the same.
So here, we're making
up a language.
And in fact, that's a very
nice thing to be doing.
It's so much fun to make
up a language.
And you do this all the time.
And the really most powerful
design things you ever do are
sort of making up a language to
solve problems like this.
Now, here we go back here and
look at some of these rules.
Well, there's a whole
set of them.
I mean, there's one for
addition and one for
multiplication, just
like we had before.
The derivative of the product of
x1 and x2 with respect to v
is the sum of the product of x1
and the derivative x2 with
respect to v and the
product of the
derivative of x1 and x2.
And here we have
exponentiation.
And, of course, we run off
the end down here.
We get as many as we like.
But the whole thing over here,
I'm giving this--this list of
rules the name "derivative
rules."
What would we do with such
a thing once we have it?
Well, one of the nicest ideas,
first of all, is I'm going to
write for you, and we're going
to play with it all day.
What I'm going to write for
you is a program called
simplifier, the general-purpose
simplifier.
And we're going to say something
like define dsimp to
be a simplifier of the
derivative rules.
And what simplifier is going
to do is, given a set of
rules, it will produce for
me a procedure which will
simplify expressions containing
the things that are
referred to by these rules.
So here will be a procedure
constructed for your purposes
to simplify things with
derivatives in them such that,
after that, if we're typing at
some list system, and we get a
prompt, and we say dsimp, for
example, of the derivative of
the sum of x and y with
respect to x--
note the quote here because
I'm talking about the
expression which is
the derivative--
then I will get back as
a result plus 1 0.
Because the derivative of x plus
y is the derivative of x
plus derivative y.
The derivative of x with
respect to x is 1.
The derivative of y with
respect to x is 0.
It's not what we're
going to get.
I haven't put any simplification
at that level--
algebraic simplification--
yet.
Of course, once we have such a
thing, then we can--then we
can look at other rules.
So, for example, we can, if
we go to the slide, OK?
Here, for example, are other
rules that we might have,
algebraic manipulation rules,
ones that would be used for
simplifying algebraic
expressions.
For example, just looking at
some of these, the left-hand
side says any operator applied
to a constant e1 and a
constant e2 is the result of
evaluating that operator on
the constants e1 and e2.
Or an operator, applied to e1,
any expression e1 and a
constant e2, is going to move
the constant forward.
So that'll turn into
the operator with
e2 followed by e1.
Why I did that, I don't know.
It wouldn't work if I had
division, for example.
So there's a bug in the
rules, if you like.
So the sum of 0 and e is e.
The product of 1 and any
expression e is e.
The product of 0 and any
expression e is 0.
Just looking at some more of
these rules, we could have
arbitrarily complicated ones.
We could have things like the
product of the constant e1 and
any constant e2 with e3 is the
result of multiplying the
result of--multiplying now the
constants e1 and e2 together
and putting e3 there.
So it says combine the constants
that I had, which
was if I had a product of e1 and
e2 and e3 just multiply--I
mean and e1 and e2 are both
constants, multiply them.
And you can make up the
rules as you like.
There are lots of them here.
There are things as complicated,
for example, as--
oh, I suppose down here some
distributive law, you see.
The product of any object c and
the sum of d and e gives
the result as the same as the
sum of the product of c and d
and the product of c and e.
Now, what exactly these
rules are doesn't very
much interest me.
We're going to be writing the
language that will allow us to
interpret these rules so that
we can, in fact, make up
whatever rules we like, another
whole language of
programming.
Well, let's see.
I haven't told you how we're
going to do this.
And, of course, for a while,
we're going to work on that.
But there's a real question of
what is--what am I going to do
at all at a large scale?
How do these rules work?
How is the simplifier program
going to manipulate these
rules with your expression to
produce a reasonable answer?
Well, first, I'd like to think
about these rules as being
some sort of deck of them.
So here I have a whole bunch
of rules, right?
Each rule--
here's a rule--
has a pattern and a skeleton.
I'm trying to make up a control
structure for this.
Now, what I have is a matcher,
and I have something which is
an instantiater.
And I'm going to pass from the
matcher to the instantiater
some set of meaning for the
pattern variables, a
dictionary, I'll call it.
A dictionary, which will say
x was matched against the
following subexpression and y
was matched against another
following subexpression.
And from the instantiater, I
will be making expressions,
and they will go into
the matcher.
They will be expressions.
And the patterns of the rules
will be fed into the matcher,
and the skeletons from the same
rule will be fed into the
instantiater.
Now, this is a little
complicated because when you
have something like an algebraic
expression, where
someth--the rules are intended
to be able to allow you to
substitute equal for equal.
These are equal transformation
rules.
So all subexpressions
of the expression
should be looked at.
You give it an expression,
this thing, and the rules
should be cycled around.
First of all, for every
subexpression of the
expression you feed in, all
of the rules must be
tried and looked at.
And if any rule matches, then
this process occurs.
The dictionary--the dictionary
is to have some values in it.
The instantiater makes a new
expression, which is basically
replaces that part of the
expression that was matched in
your original expression.
And then, then, of course, we're
going to recheck that,
going to go around these rules
again, seeing if that could be
simplified further.
And then, then we're going
to do that for every
subexpression until the thing
no longer changes.
You can think of this as sort
of an organic process.
You've got some sort
of stew, right?
You've got bacteria or
something, or enzymes in some,
in some gooey mess.
And there's these--and these
enzymes change things.
They attach to your expression,
change it, and
then they go away.
And they have to match.
The key-in-lock phenomenon.
They match, they change
it, they go away.
You can imagine it as a parallel
process of some sort.
So you stick an expression into
this mess, and after a
while, you take it out, and
it's been simplified.
And it just keeps changing
until it no
longer can be changed.
But these enzymes can attach
to any part of the, of the
expression.
OK, at this point, I'd like to
stop and ask for questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This implies that the
matching program and the
instantiation program
are separate
programs; is that right?
Or is that-- they are.
PROFESSOR: They're separate
little pieces.
They fit together in
a larger structure.
AUDIENCE: So I'm going through
and matching and passing the
information about what I matched
to an instantiater,
which makes the changes.
And then I pass that back
to the matcher?
PROFESSOR: It won't
make a change.
It will make a new expression,
which has, which has
substituted the values of the
pattern variable that were
matched on the left-hand side
for the variables that are
mentioned, the skeleton
variables or evaluation
variables or whatever I called
them, on the right-hand side.
AUDIENCE: And then that's passed
back into the matcher?
PROFESSOR: Then this is going
to go around again.
This is going to go through
this mess until
it no longer changes.
AUDIENCE: And it seems that
there would be a danger of
getting into a recursive loop.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes, if you do not write your
rules nicely, you are--
indeed, in any programming
language you invent, if it's
sufficiently powerful to do
anything, you can write
programs that will go
into infinite loops.
And indeed, writing a program
for doing algebraic
manipulation for long will
produce infinite loops.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Some language
designers feel that this
feature is so important that it
should become part of the
basic language, for example,
scheme in this case.
What are your thoughts on--
PROFESSOR: Which language
feature?
AUDIENCE: The pairs matching.
It's all application of
such rules should be--
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
mean like Prolog?
AUDIENCE: Like Prolog, but it
becomes a more general--
PROFESSOR: It's possible.
OK, I think my feeling about
that is that I would like to
teach you how to do it so you
don't depend upon some
language designer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: You make
it yourself.
You can roll your own.
Thank you.
Well, let's see.
Now we have to tell
you how it works.
It conveniently breaks up
into various pieces.
I'd like to look now
at the matcher.
The matcher has the following
basic structure.
It's a box that takes as its
input an expression and a
pattern, and it turns
out a dictionary.
A dictionary, remember, is a
mapping of pattern variables
to the values that were found
by matching, and it puts out
another dictionary, which is the
result of augmenting this
dictionary by what was found
in matching this expression
against this pattern.
So that's the matcher.
Now, this is a rather
complicated program, and we
can look at it on the overhead
over here and see, ha, ha,
it's very complicated.
I just want you to look
at the shape of it.
It's too complicated to look
at except in pieces.
However, it's a fairly large,
complicated program with a lot
of sort of indented structure.
At the largest scale--
you don't try to read those
characters, but at the largest
scale, you see that there is a
case analysis, which is all
these cases lined up.
What we're now going to do is
look at this in a bit more
detail, attempting to understand
how it works.
Let's go now to the first slide,
showing some of the
structure of the matcher
at a large scale.
And we see that the matcher, the
matcher takes as its input
a pattern, an expression,
and a dictionary.
And there is a case analysis
here, which is made out of
several cases, some of which
have been left out over here,
and the general case, which
I'd like you to see.
Let's consider this
general case.
It's a very important pattern.
The problem is that we have
to examine two trees
simultaneously.
One of the trees is the tree
of the expression, and the
other is the tree
of the pattern.
We have to compare them with
each other so that the
subexpressions of the expression
are matched against
subexpressions of the pattern.
Looking at that in a bit more
detail, suppose I had a
pattern, a pattern, which was
the sum of the product of a
thing which we will call x and
a thing which we will call y,
and the sum of that, and the
same thing we call y.
So we're looking for a sum of a
product whose second--whose
second argument is the
same as the second
argument of the sum.
That's a thing you might
be looking for.
Well, that, as a pattern,
looks like this.
There is a tree, which consists
of a sum, and a
product with a pattern variable
question mark x and
question mark y, the other
pattern variable, and question
mark y, just looking at the
same, just writing down the
list structure in
a different way.
Now, suppose we were matching
that against an expression
which matches it, the sum of,
say, the product of 3 and x
and, say, x.
That's another tree.
It's the sum of the product
of 3 and x and of x.
So what I want to do is traverse
these two trees
simultaneously.
And what I'd like to do is
walk them like this.
I'm going to say are
these the same?
This is a complicated object.
Let's look at the
left branches.
Well, that could be the car.
How does that look?
Oh yes, the plus looks
just fine.
But the next thing here is
a complicated thing.
Let's look at that.
Oh yes, that's pretty
fine, too.
They're both asterisks.
Now, whoops!
My pattern variable, it
matches against the 3.
Remember, x equals 3 now.
That's in my dictionary, and
the dictionary's going to
follow along with me:
x equals three.
Ah yes, x equals 3 and y
equals x, different x.
The pattern x is the expression
x, the pattern y.
Oh yes, the pattern variable
y, I've already
got a value for it.
It's x.
Is this an x?
Oh yeah, sure it is.
That's fine.
Yep, done.
I now have a dictionary,
which I've accumulated
by making this walk.
Well, now let's look at this
general case here and see how
that works.
Here we have it.
I take in a pattern variable--a
pattern, an
expression, and a dictionary.
And now I'm going to do a
complicated thing here, which
is the general case.
The expression is made out of
two parts: a left and a right
half, in general.
Anything that's complicated is
made out of two pieces in a
Lisp system.
Well, now what do
we have here?
I'm going to match the car's of
the two expressions against
each other with respect to the
dictionary I already have,
producing a dictionary as its
value, which I will then use
for matching the cdr's
against each other.
So that's how the dictionary
travels,
threads the entire structure.
And then the result of that is
the dictionary for the match
of the car and the cdr, and
that's what's going to be
returned as a value.
Now, at any point, a
match might fail.
It may be the case, for example,
if we go back and
look at an expression that
doesn't quite match, like
supposing this was a 4.
Well, now these two don't match
any more, because the x
that had to be-- sorry, the y
that had to be x here and this
y has to be 4.
But x and 4 were not the same
object syntactically.
So this wouldn't match, and
that would be rejected
sometimes, so matches
may fail.
Now, of course, because this
matcher takes the dictionary
from the previous match as
input, it must be able to
propagate the failures.
And so that's what the
first clause of
this conditional does.
It's also true that if it turned
out that the pattern
was not atomic--
see, if the pattern was atomic,
I'd go into this
stuff, which we haven't
looked at yet.
But if the pattern is
not atomic and the
expression is atomic--
it's not made out of pieces--
then that must be a failure,
and so we go over here.
If the pattern is not atomic
and the pattern is not a
pattern variable--
I have to remind myself
of that--
then we go over here.
So that way, failures
may occur.
OK, so now let's look at the
insides of this thing.
Well, the first place to look
is what happens if I have an
atomic pattern?
That's very simple.
A pattern that's not made
out of any pieces: foo.
That's a nice atomic pattern.
Well, here's what we see.
If the pattern is atomic, then
if the expression is atomic,
then if they are the same thing,
then the dictionary I
get is the same one
as I had before.
Nothing's changed.
It's just that I matched plus
against plus, asterisk against
asterisk, x against x.
That's all fine.
However, if the pattern is
not the one which is the
expression, if I have two
separate atomic objects, then
it was matching plus against
asterisk, which case I fail.
Or if it turns out that the
pattern is atomic but the
expression is complicated,
it's not atomic,
then I get a failure.
That's very simple.
Now, what about the various
kinds of pattern variables?
We had three kinds.
I give them the names.
They're arbitrary constants,
arbitrary variables, and
arbitrary expressions.
A question mark x is an
arbitrary expression.
A question mark cx is an
arbitrary constant, and a
question mark vx is an
arbitrary variable.
Well, what do we do here?
Looking at this, we see that
if I have an arbitrary
constant, if the pattern is an
arbitrary constant, then it
had better be the case
that the expression
had better be a constant.
If the expression is
not a constant,
then that match fails.
If it is a constant, however,
then I wish to extend the
dictionary.
I wish to extend the dictionary
with that pattern
being remembered to be that
expression using the old
dictionary as a starting
point.
So really, for arbitrary
variables, I have to check
first if the expression is a
variable by matching against.
If so, it's worth extending
the dictionary so that the
pattern is remembered to
be matched against that
expression, given the original
dictionary, and this makes a
new dictionary.
Now, it has to check.
There's a sorts of failure
inside extend dictionary,
which is that--
if one of these pattern
variables already has a value
and I'm trying to match the
thing against something else
which is not equivalent to the
one that I've already matched
it against once, then a failure
will come flying out
of here, too.
And I will see that some time.
And finally, an arbitrary
expression does not have to
check anything syntactic about
the expression that's being
matched, so all it does is
it's an extension of the
dictionary.
So you've just seen a complete,
very simple matcher.
Now, one of the things that's
rather remarkable about this
is people pay an awful lot of
money these days for someone
to make a, quote, AI expert
system that has nothing more
in it than a matcher and maybe
an instantiater like this.
But it's very easy to do, and
now, of course, you can start
up a little start-up company and
make a couple of megabucks
in the next week taking some
people for a ride.
20 years ago, this
was remarkable,
this kind of program.
But now, this is sort of easy.
You can teach it to freshmen.
Well, now there's an
instantiater as well.
The problem is they're all
going off and making more
money than I do.
But that's always been
true of universities.
As expression, the purpose of
the instantiater is to make
expressions given a dictionary
and a skeleton.
And that's not very
hard at all.
We'll see that very simply in
the next, the next slide here.
To instantiate a skeleton,
given a particular
dictionary--
oh, this is easy.
We're going to do a recursive
tree walk over the skeleton.
And for everything which is
a skeleton variable--
I don't know, call it a
skeleton evaluation.
That's the name and the abstract
syntax that I give it
in this program: a skeleton
evaluation, a thing beginning
with a colon in the rules.
For anything of that case, I'm
going to look up the answer in
the dictionary, and we'll worry
about that in a second.
Let's look at this as a whole.
Here, I have--
I'm going to instantiate a
skeleton, given a dictionary.
Well, I'm going to define some
internal loop right there, and
it's going to do something
very simple.
Even if a skeleton--even if a
skeleton is simple and atomic,
in which case it's nothing more
than giving the skeleton
back as an answer, or in
the general case, it's
complicated, in which case
I'm going to make up the
expression which is the result
of instantiating--
calling this loop
recursively--
instantiating the car of the
skeleton and the cdr.
So here is a recursive
tree walk.
However, if it turns out to be a
skeleton evaluation, a colon
expression in the skeleton, then
what I'm going to do is
find the expression that's
in the colon--
the CADR in this case.
It's a piece of abstract syntax
here, so I can change
my representation of rules.
I'm going to evaluate that
relative to this dictionary,
whatever evaluation means.
We'll find out a lot about
that sometime.
And the result of that
is my answer.
so.
I start up this loop-- here's
my initialization--
by calling it with the whole
skeleton, and this will just
do a recursive decomposition
into pieces.
Now, one more little bit
of detail is what
happens inside evaluate?
I can't tell you that
in great detail.
I'll tell you a little
bit of it.
Later, we're going to see--look
into this in much
more detail.
To evaluate some form, some
expression with respect to a
dictionary, if the expression is
an atomic object, well, I'm
going to go look it up.
Nothing very exciting there.
Otherwise, I'm going to do
something complicated here,
which is I'm going to apply a
procedure which is the result
of looking up the operator part
in something that we're
going to find out
about someday.
I want you realize you're
seeing magic now.
This magic will become clear
very soon, but not today.
Then I'm looking at--looking
up all the pieces, all the
arguments to that in
the dictionary.
So I don't want you to look
at this in detail.
I want you to say that there's
more going on here, and we're
going to see more about this.
But it's--
the magic is going to stop.
This part has to do with Lisp,
and it's the end of that.
OK, so now we know about
matching and instantiation.
Are there any questions
for this segment?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
bring up a previous slide?
It's about this define
match pattern.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You'd like to see the overall
slide define match pattern.
Can somebody put up the--
no, the overhead.
That's the biggest scale one.
What part would you
like to see?
AUDIENCE: Well, the
top would be fine.
Any of the parts where you're
passing failed.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The idea is to pass
failed back to the dictionary;
is that right?
PROFESSOR: The dictionary is the
answer to a match, right?
And it is either some mapping
or there's no match.
It doesn't match.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So what you're seeing
over here is, in fact,
because the fact that a match
may have another match pass in
the dictionary, as you see in
the general case down here.
Here's the general case where
a match passes another match
to the dictionary.
When I match the cdr's, I match
them in the dictionary
that is resulting from
matching the car's.
OK, that's what I have here.
So because of that, if the match
of the car's fails, then
it may be necessary that the
match of the cdr's propagates
that failure, and that's
what the first line is.
AUDIENCE: OK, well, I'm still
unclear what matches--
what comes out of one instance
of the match?
PROFESSOR: One of two
possibilities.
Either the symbol failed, which
means there is no match.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Or some mapping,
which is an abstract thing
right now, and you should know
about the structure of it,
which relates the pattern
variables to their values as
picked up in the match.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it is--
PROFESSOR: That's constructed
by extend dictionary.
AUDIENCE: So the recursive
nature brings about the fact
that if ever a failed gets
passed out of any calling of
match, then the first condition
will pick it up--
PROFESSOR: And just propagate
it along without any further
ado, right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, right.
OK.
PROFESSOR: That's just the
fastest way to get that
failure out of there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If I don't fail, that
means that I've matched a
pattern, and I run the procedure
extend dict and then
pass in the pattern
in the expression.
But the substitution will
not be made at that
point; is that right?
I'm just--
PROFESSOR: No, no.
There's no substitution being
there because there's no
skeleton to be substituted in.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So what--
PROFESSOR: All you've got there
is we're making up the
dictionary for later
substitution.
AUDIENCE: And what would the
dictionary look like?
Is it ordered pairs?
PROFESSOR: That's--that's
not told to you.
We're being abstract.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Why do you
want to know?
What it is, it's a function.
It's a function.
AUDIENCE: Well, the reason
I want to know is--
PROFESSOR: A function
abstractly is a
set of ordered pairs.
It could be implemented as
a set of list pairs.
It could be implemented as some
fancy table mechanism.
It could be implemented
as a function.
And somehow, I'm building
up a function.
But I'm not telling you.
That's up to George, who's going
to build that later.
I know you really badly want
to write concrete things.
I'm not going to let
you do that.
AUDIENCE: Well, let me at
least ask, what is the
important information
there that's being
passed to extend dict?
I want to pass the
pattern I found--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The pattern that's matched
against the expression.
You want to have the pattern,
which happens to be in those
cases pattern variables,
right?
All of those three
cases for extend
dict are pattern variables.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So you have a pattern
variable that is to be
given a value in a dictionary.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
PROFESSOR: The value is the
expression that it matched
against. The dictionary is the
set of things I've already
figured out that I have
memorized or learned.
And I am going to make a new
dictionary, which is extended
from the original one by having
that pattern variable
have a value with the
new dictionary.
AUDIENCE: I guess what I don't
understand is why can't the
substitution be made right
as soon as you find--
PROFESSOR: How do I know what
I'm going to substitute?
I don't know anything
about this skeleton.
This pattern, this matcher
is an independent unit.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I take the matcher.
I apply the matcher.
If it matches, then it was worth
doing instantiation.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK?
AUDIENCE: Can you just do that
answer again using that
example on the board?
You know, what you just passed
back to the matcher.
PROFESSOR: Oh yes.
OK, yes.
You're looking at
this example.
At this point when I'm
traversing this structure, I
get to here: x.
I have some dictionary,
presumably an empty dictionary
at this point if this is
the whole expression.
So I have an empty dictionary,
and I've matched x against 3.
So now, after this point,
the dictionary
contains x is 3, OK?
Now, I continue walking
along here.
I see y.
Now, this is a particular
x, a pattern x.
I see y, a pattern y.
The dictionary says, oh yes, the
pattern y is the symbol x
because I've got
a match there.
So the dictionary now contains
at this point two entries.
The pattern x is 3, and the
pattern y is the expression x.
Now, I get that, I can
walk along further.
I say, oh, pattern y
also wants to be 4.
But that isn't possible,
producing a failure.
Thank you.
Let's take a break.
OK, you're seeing your first
very big and hairy program.
Now, of course, one of the goals
of this subsegment is to
get you to be able to read
something like this and not be
afraid of it.
This one's only about
four pages of code.
By the end of the subject, I
hope a 50-page program will
not look particularly
frightening.
But I don't expect-- and I don't
want you to think that I
expect you to be getting
it as it's coming out.
You're supposed to feel the
flavor of this, OK?
And then you're supposed to
think about it because it is a
big program.
There's a lot of stuff
inside this program.
Now, I've told you about the
language we're implementing,
the pattern match substitution
language.
I showed you some rules.
And I've told you about matching
and instantiation,
which are the two halves
of how a rule works.
Now we have to understand the
control structure by which the
rules are applied to the
expressions so as to do
algebraic simplification.
Now, that's also a big
complicated mess.
The problem is that there is
a variety of interlocking,
interwoven loops, if you
will, involved in this.
For one thing, I
have to apply--
I have to examine every
subexpression of my expression
that I'm trying to simplify.
That we know how to do.
It's a car cdr recursion of some
sort, or something like
that, and some sort
of tree walk.
And that's going to
be happening.
Now, for every such place, every
node that I get to in
doing my traversal of the
expression I'm trying to
simplify, I want to apply
all of the rules.
Every rule is going to
look at every node.
I'm going to rotate
the rules around.
Now, either a rule will
or will not match.
If the rule does not match,
then it's not very
interesting.
If the rule does match, then I'm
going to replace that node
in the expression by an
alternate expression.
I'm actually going
to make a new
expression, which contains--
everything contains that new
value, the result of
substituting into the skeleton,
instantiating the
skeleton for that rule
at this level.
But no one knows whether that
thing that I instantiated
there is in simplified form.
So we're going to have to
simplify that, somehow to call
the simplifier on the thing
that I just constructed.
And then when that's done, then
I sort of can build that
into the expression I
want as my answer.
Now, there is a basic idea
here, which I will call a
garbage- in, garbage-out
simplifier.
It's a kind of recursive
And what happens is the way you
simplify something is that
simple objects like variables
are simple.
Compound objects, well,
I don't know.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to build up from simple
objects, trying to make simple
things by assuming that the
pieces they're made
out of are simple.
That's what's happening here.
Well, now, if we look
at the first slide--
no, overhead, overhead.
If we look at the overhead, we
see a very complicated program
like we saw before for the
matcher, so complicated that
you can't read it like that.
I just want you to get the feel
of the shape of it, and
the shape of it is that this
program has various
subprograms in it.
One of them--this part is the
part for traversing the
expression, and this part is
the part for trying rules.
Now, of course, we can look at
that in some more detail.
Let's look at--let's look at the
first transparency, right?
The simplifier is made
out of several parts.
Now, remember at the very
beginning, the simplifier is
the thing which takes a rules--a
set of rules and
produces a program which will
simplify it relative to them.
So here we have our
simplifier.
It takes a rule set.
And in the context where that
rule set is defined, there are
various other definitions
that are done here.
And then the result of this
simplifier procedure is, in
fact, one of the procedures
that was defined.
Simplify x.
What I'm returning as the
value of calling the
simplifier on a set of rules is
a procedure, the simplify x
procedure, which is defined in
that context, which is a
simplification procedure
appropriate for using those
set of rules.
That's what I have there.
Now, the first two of these
procedures, this one and this
one, are together going to be
the recursive traversal of an
expression.
This one is the general
simplification for any
expression, and this is the
thing which simplifies a list
of parts of an expression.
Nothing more.
For each of those, we're going
to do something complicated,
which involves trying
the rules.
Now, we should look at
the various parts.
Well let's look first at the
recursive traversal of an
expression.
And this is done in a
sort of simple way.
This is a little nest of
recursive procedures.
And what we have here
are two procedures--
one for simplifying an
expression, and one for
simplifying parts of
an expression.
And the way this works
is very simple.
If the expression I'm trying
to simplify is a compound
expression, I'm going to
simplify all the parts of it.
And that's calling--that
procedure, simplify parts, is
going to make up a new
expression with all the parts
simplified, which I'm then
going to try the
rules on over here.
If it turns out that the
expression is not compound, if
it's simple, like just a symbol
or something like pi,
then in any case, I'm going to
try the rules on it because it
might be that I want in my set
of rules to expand pi to
3.14159265358979,
dot, dot, dot.
But I may not.
But there is no reason
not to do it.
Now, if I want to simplify the
parts, well, that's easy too.
Either the expression is an
empty one, there's no more
parts, in which case I have
the empty expression.
Otherwise, I'm going to make a
new expression by cons, which
is the result of simplifying
the first part of the
expression, the car, and
simplifying the rest of the
expression, which is the cdr.
Now, the reason why I'm showing
you this sort of stuff
this way is because I want you
get the feeling for the
various patterns that are very
important when writing
programs. And this could be
written a different way.
There's another way to write
simplified expressions so
there would be only
one of them.
There would only be one
little procedure here.
Let me just write that on the
blackboard to give you a
feeling for that.
This in another idiom,
if you will.
To simplify an expression
called x, what
am I going to do?
I'm going to try the rules on
the following situation.
If--
on the following expression--
compound, just like
we had before.
If the expression is compound,
well, what am I going to do?
I'm going to simplify
all the parts.
But I already have a cdr
recursion, a common pattern of
usage, which has been captured
as a high-order procedure.
It's called map.
So I'll just write that here.
Map simplify the expression,
all the parts of the
expression.
This says apply the
simplification operation,
which is this one, every part
of the expression, and then
that cuts those up into a list.
It's every element of
the list which the expression is
assumed to be made out of,
and otherwise, I have
the expression.
So I don't need the helper
procedure, simplify parts,
because that's really this.
So sometimes, you just
write it this way.
It doesn't matter very much.
Well, now let's take
a look at--
let's just look at how
you try rules.
If you look at this slide,
we see this is a
complicated mess also.
I'm trying rules on
an expression.
It turns out the expression
I'm trying it on is some
subexpression now of the
expression I started with.
Because the thing I just
arranged allowed us to try
every subexpression.
So now here we're taking in
a subexpression of the
expression we started with.
That's what this is.
And what we're going to define
here is a procedure called
scan, which is going
to try every rule.
And we're going to start it up
on the whole set of rules.
This is going to go cdr-ing down
the rules, if you will,
looking for a rule to apply.
And when it finds one,
it'll do the job.
Well, let's take a look at
how try rules works.
It's very simple:
the scan rules.
Scan rules, the way
of scanning.
Well, is it so simple?
It's a big program, of course.
We take a bunch of rules,
which is a sublist
of the list of rules.
We've tried some of them
already, and they've not been
appropriate, so we
get to some here.
We get to move to
the next one.
If there are no more rules, well
then, there's nothing I
can do with this expression,
and it's simplified.
However, if it turns out that
there are still rules to be
done, then let's match the
pattern of the first rule
against the expression using the
empty dictionary to start
with and use that as
the dictionary.
If that happens to
be a failure, try
the rest of the rules.
That's all it says here.
It says discard that rule.
Otherwise, well, I'm going to
get the skeleton of the first
rule, instantiate that relative
to the dictionary,
and simplify the result, and
that's the expression I want.
So although that was a
complicated program, every
complicated program is made out
of a lot of simple pieces.
Now, the pattern of recursions
here is very complicated.
And one of the most important
things is not
to think about that.
If you try to think about the
actual pattern by which this
does something, you're going
to get very confused.
I would.
This is not a matter of you
can do this with practice.
These patterns are hard.
But you don't have to
think about it.
The key to this--
it's very good programming and
very good design-- is to know
what not to think about.
The fact is, going back to this
slide, I don't have to
think about it because I have
specifications in my mind for
what simplify x does.
I don't have to know
how it does it.
And it may, in fact, call scan
somehow through try rules,
which it does.
And somehow, I've got another
recursion going on here.
But since I know that simplify
x is assumed by wishful
thinking to produce the
simplified result, then I
don't have to think
about it anymore.
I've used it.
I've used it in a
reasonable way.
I will get a reasonable
answer.
And you have to learn how
to program that way--
with abandon.
Well, there's very little
left of this thing.
All there is left is a few
details associated with what a
dictionary is.
And those of you who've been
itching to know what a
dictionary is, well, I will flip
it up and not tell you
anything about it.
Dictionaries are easy.
It's represented in terms of
something else called an A
list, which is a particular
pattern of usage for making
tables in lists.
They're easy.
They're made out of pairs,
as was asked a bit ago.
And there are special procedures
for dealing with
such things called assq, and you
can find them in manuals.
I'm not terribly excited
about it.
The only interesting thing here
in extend dictionary is I
have to extend the dictionary
with a pattern, a datum, and a
dictionary.
This pattern is, in fact, at
this point a pattern variable.
And what do I want to do?
I want to pull out the name of
that pattern variable, the
pattern variable name, and I'm
going to look up in the
dictionary and see if it
already has a value.
If not, I'm going to
add a new one in.
If it does have one, if it has a
value, then it had better be
equal to the one that was
already stored away.
And if that's the case, the
dictionary is what I
expected it to be.
Otherwise, I fail.
So that's easy, too.
If you open up any program,
you're going to find inside of
it lots of little pieces,
all of which are easy.
So at this point, I suppose,
I've just told you some
million-dollar valuable
information.
And I suppose at this point
we're pretty much done with
this program.
I'd like to ask about
questions.
AUDIENCE: Yes, can you give me
the words that describe the
specification for a simplified
expression?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
A simplified expression takes
an expression and produces a
simplified expression.
That's it, OK?
How it does it is very easy.
In compound expressions, all the
pieces are simplified, and
then the rules are tried
on the result.
And for simple expressions, you
just try all the rules.
AUDIENCE: So an expression
is simplified by
virtue of the rules?
PROFESSOR: That's,
of course, true.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: And the way this
works is that simplifi
expression, as you see here,
what it does is it breaks the
expression down into the
smallest pieces, simplifies
building up from the bottom
using the rules to be the
simplifier, to do the
manipulations, and constructs
a new expression
as the result.
Eventually, one of things you
see is that the rules
themselves, the try rules, call
a simplified expression
on the results when it changes
something, the
results of a match.
I'm sorry, the results of
instantiation of a skeleton
for a rule that has matched.
So the spec of a simplified
expression is that any
expression you put into it comes
out simplified according
to those rules.
Thank you.
Let's take a break.